direction château la vallière dans le
nord touraine depuis plusieurs années
les passionnés de l'association cyclo
rail 37 milite pour la restauration de
l'ancienne voie entre la gare castel
valérie yens et celle de l'ubs les sept
kilomètres plus loin
cette semaine un nouveau cap a été
franchi fini les pioches et les
tronçonneuses pour ses retraités
ils ont fait appel à une entreprise
spécialisée dans le débroussaillage de
quoi mettre leur activité touristique
sur de bons rails
hélène chaplin nous les avions
rencontrés il ya un an de cela les
bénévoles de l'association cyclo raya
château la vallière avait alors dégagé
par eux mêmes un kilomètre de voie
ferrée qu'ils avaient ouvert aux
touristes
aujourd'hui nous les retrouverons avec
des moyens beaucoup plus conséquents
grâce à une subvention du conseil
départemental nos ferro vif ils ont pu
se payer les services d'une pelleteuse
rail-route un engin de vingt-et-une
tonnes qui est en train de dégager les
cinq derniers kilomètres qui séparent la
gare de l'ubs les de celle de
château-la-vallière on fait une grosse
débroussailleuse pour broyer tout ce qui
est tout ce que végétaux tout ce qui est
petit végétaux ça roule sur les rails et
puis ça ça broie à mesure
le dernier train qui est passé c'est un
train de fret qui venait de château du
loir qui desservait la gare de l'ubs les
le silo et diverses entreprises
ça c'est en 1981 depuis la végétation a
repris ses droits
tout est constatée avant et après c'est
le jour et la nuit
et pour s'assurer de la qualité du
travail effectué et rien de mieux que de
tester la ligne fraîchement dégager de
les vacances de pâques elle les vélos
rails de l'association devrait donc
reprendre du service pour des parcours
plus long de 3 ou 6 km pour sa première
année d'exploitation en 2020
l'association a accueilli près de 2000
touristes